[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him impeach him
now $8 million in bribe payments to the
president of the United States while he
is in office I am
demanding he be in be wait wait which
which president was
it oh
oh I'm sorry wrong
guy wrong guy I thought it was I thought
it was like the current one was taking
$8 million from China in his private
business with him and his son yeah oops
oops as if we didn't know the president
with the Chinese Bank accounts is is is
taking Chinese bribes come on
man kidding
me just like we're supposed to believe
that the guy who paled around with Jeff
Jeffrey
Epstein raped a 13-year-old girl with
Jeffrey that's a thing it was a lawsuit
just court documents
testimony no matter what the fash wants
to tell you he was on the flight list he
was on there do you know who's not on
there do know who doesn't have Chinese
bank
accounts do you know who didn't take $8
million from China in a bribe do you
know isn't on the flight list do you
know isn't in in the in the Epstein
files you knew his name doesn't
appear Joe
Biden Barack Obama either I mean if you
really want to get you know Fancy with
it
and I don't think that really
matters but neither one of
them neither one of them have the stench
of Uncle Jeffrey
right and they want they want a yelling
scream Bill Clinton Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton [__] Bill
Clinton the F we're not We're Not Gonna
vote ever for Bill
Clinton
ever just like we're not gonna vote for
[__] Hunter Biden ever we we we're
not GNA vote for him what are you
talking
about yell yell and scream all you want
you [__] [__]
eaters Joe Biden has been a politician
for many many many decades many
decades plenty plenty plenty of
opportunity to have taken advantage
of what Uncle Jeffrey got other
politicians to take advantage
of or presidents if you want to say
presidents let's just leave it at
presidents shall we I mean can we do
that we should just leave it there
because both of the presidents the
United States presidents the presidents
of the United States the former
presidents that ended up on this
list when they ended up on the list and
in the files it it was when they weren't
presidents of the United
States Joe Biden is the current one and
he wasn't the president of the United
States for a long time before that like
a long time before
that
so have at
it oh by the way by the way speaking
speaking of news about Brandon did you
did you hear not only not only do we
need to blame the lowering of gas prices
on Brandon okay but also there was over
300 200 300,000
jobs created in
December this [__] son this son of a
[__] and
and Brandon made sure when the
Republicans went down to the border for
their photo op the other day Brandon
made sure that all the migrants didn't
come across the border that day that it
was just dead yeah what they weren't
serving that day you know what I
mean oh man listen I I I do
not um want to oppose Mike Johnson or
the Republicans the House Republicans
going to the boorder every single day um
so that that way no migrants come across
the border where they're at during that
time because that's kind of how they
spun it they're like oh the reason why
they didn't come across that day is
because we were there or some stupid
dumb [__] like like
that yes I'm being corrected 216,000 new
jobs for December
216,000 I couldn't remember 200 300 what
the [__] [__] what what's the difference
when you're talking about Brandon jobs
really are these really jobs if they're
Brandon jobs are they Fox News seems to
think so I got a couple clips of Fox
News really really really hating to love
dark Brandon's economic
accomplishments
oh man so here's the thing is yesterday
I rambled on and on and on I made a lot
of people mad because I rambled on and
on and on about messaging and narrative
and and this is this is a good time to
to um make sure we we make this point is
that it is important um to you know
point out the
accomplishments of the current president
of the United States the guy that we
want to win because of democracy and
[__] not not because he is such a great
president he's done a great job but not
because of that um it's because of the
other [__] I'm going to show you
a video today that the guy the dude
Grandpa Hitler posted on true social and
holy [__] holy Nazi [__] holy Nazi [__]
it's crazy no it's a crazy one and
there's another there's another video
out by 11 films about what would happen
if Donald Trump did become dict taster
of the United States if Grandpa Hitler
got his way um it it kind of spells out
what America might look like the new
America not the United States of America
but the new America what it would look
like which is kind of crazy so I'm gonna
show you I'm gonna show you that video
too um and also also back to the Tony
Michaels podcast we have bonee head of
the week and we're going to do some sort
of year in review
2023 uh I think I think it's pretty
obvious who
won bonehead of the year in
2023 it is 2024 big step fan make sure
to correct me if I get my ear wrong
today I know you were correcting me over
from twitch yesterday in the chat so
correct me if I get my ear wrong today
but we're gonna have the guy with the
last name Sanchez that's right Gabe
Sanchez is gonna join us for bonehead of
the year so you're GNA get you some um
you're going to get you some Sanchez
crack today on the Tony Michaels podcast
so that that's exciting next week is our
our our full week
back from the Tony Michaels podcast and
we're going to go balls deep on these
these [__] eaters from now until the
election uh we might have to take a few
days off for the summer holidays but
other than that we're going to be on
five days a week Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific so
don't forget to hit the Subscribe button
you're not going to want to miss a
single episode even the ones that piss
you off
ah you knew I was going to get back
around to this yesterday we talked a lot
about messaging and narrative and how
the messaging and narrative Cascades out
no matter who is doing the messaging or
the narrative it Cascades out and that's
important so when we're talking about
the accomplishments of Brandon right it
really you need to do it in a way where
you're
mocking uh the fash right A lot of
people want a cheerlead they're like you
know go Biden right yeah hey Biden and
that's kind of the wrong way to do it
the proper way to do it is to mock it's
always to mock them right and and and
again this morning there's a report that
the Democrats have found $8
million of Chinese money that went to
Trump and his
son and I don't know if it went on his
son's laptop I don't know what's on Don
J's laptop but I think now that we know
that there is a don Junior laptop we
definitely need to investigate and we
need to investigate the investigators
don't you agree I believe that's what we
need to do especially now that we know
that there's bribe money coming from
from coming from Donald Trump Jr to
Donald Trump while he was President of
the United States the president's son
was selling influence around the world
to our Chinese
enemy $8 million of China's money it
into the pocket of Donald Trump Jr and
the Trump organization only only to
Pedal
influence to the White House in the Oval
Office under the Trump
administration every [__] accusation
all of them every [__] one of
them don't don't count out any of
them it's all projection and all a
confession all of
it every [__] one of them and you can
almost bet on it right so that's what I
want I want you to understand about the
messaging in the narrative is that
listen I've been mocking them about this
Hunter Biden stuff for [__] years
because it it never had any teeth in it
whatsoever it never felt like it had
teeth it always felt like projection and
the reason why is because their
accusations against Joe Baden and Hunter
badden were always exactly what the
trumps were doing out loud in the open I
mean Jesus Christ when Trump was
President aanka Trump received she was
she was on the she was on the payroll of
the United States government she was an
official not Donald Trump Jr Ivanka
Trump received Chinese
patents for products that were going to
make her money while she while she was a
US government official under the Trump
Administration she went to
China to represent us and she came back
with a handful of profitable patents
okay so it it's not like they weren't
doing this out in the [__] open I
mean Jesus Christ Jared Kushner who has
never never managed to fund in his
entire [__] life all of a sudden a
couple days after Donald Trump isn't
President anymore gets $2 billion dollar
in Saudi money now here's the thing
folks the patent thing that's legal I I
I I know I know I want to sit here and
be like put him in jail put him in jail
put him in jail put him in jail but
that's
legal that's the type of pedaling
influence that maybe we should consider
if it should be legal or not the2
billion dollar that Jared Kushner got
from the
Saudis probably legal probably legal I
mean can we investigate it can we make
it transparent can we show the world
what the hell they actually did sure I
mean I'm not opposed to that I mean hell
that's some pretty good [__]
messaging and narrative going into going
into 2024 When Donald Trump wants to be
the dictator I mean imagine imagine this
imagine this Donald Trump during his
four first four years in office took $8
million in Chinese money as bribes I'm
almost sure of it I mean that's the
question isn't it did he take $8 million
in Chinese money for bribes now I know
it's not 8 million a lot of people going
to correct me that's the point I want to
show you that here in a
minute but what is he going to do when
he becomes the
dictator what who is he gonna sell out
to when he becomes the dictator when no
one can take him out of power when no
one can vote him out when he becomes
dictator for that one day which leads
into the next day and the next day and
next week next month next year that's
how dictatorship
works it's called
authoritarianism who is he going to sell
out to then I mean he was willing to
sell out to to China before he was the
was the dict I mean he tried to he tried
to overthrow her government become the
fearer you know he tried the coup thing
didn't work out for
him when you're just no good at cing I
guess right because you got a bunch of
ninga poop Nazis working for
you it happens that
way but that's what we need to do we
need to mock every single piece of this
right and you use Brandon's
accomplishments as a tool of
mockery that's what you do the gas
prices the job
numbers the fact that Joe Biden didn't
appear anywhere on Epstein [__] anywhere
all that I mean I don't know if that's
an accomplishment really though is it
that that you had nothing I mean I don't
know that that's an
accomplishment I mean most people just
don't you know P around with sex
traffickers most people don't so you
know it's kind of like a standard thing
you know what I mean it's like a pretty
low
bar I mean isn't it should it should be
right it should be a low bar that you
just don't P around with a bunch of
[__] sex traffickers I don't know
maybe I'm maybe maybe I'm wildly out of
step with most of America let's get back
to the messaging on the um on the $8
million of Chinese money because I
that's not the real the real numbers I I
I think it's like $7.8 million total
that they found so far and I think five
a half million dollar something like
that is from China and I think there's
like 23 other foreign countries that
they were receiving money from that they
found these were bribe pay bribe
payments I don't know I mean seems like
they could be these are questions that
Congress needs to ask I'm sure and make
sure they get to the bottom of these
payments that were made uh to the presid
president son
and trickling down to the president it's
way I see it exactly what they're
accusing Joe Biden of but here's the
thing when you tell when you say that
[__] out loud like $8 million a Chinese
money Donald Trump got right what's
gonna happen is the [__] eaters are
gonna be like oh you're so dumb you're
such a dumb liberal that ain't the
numbers okay he took five A5 million
doll from China the rest of it was from
20 23 other countries and then what you
say is like you know what you are you're
correct [__] eater thanks for pointing
that out for me thanks for correcting me
and giving me the facts I mean that's
how you trick them into admitting [__]
right that's how you trick them into it
and that's the beautiful part is you use
mockery you use a little bit of
stretching to get them there this is how
the right does it all the time This Is
How They bait us into stupid [__] all
the time they continue to do it it's the
gas stoves the M&M's all that [__] the
[__] Bud Light [__] it's all that
[__] that they bait us into having to
have these [__] conversations about
how talking how stupid they
are right so play dumb a little bit play
dumb a little bit bait them
in hook them sink
them we we we've only got a couple
couple months to do this uh the
primaries are in full swing uh the the I
was looking at the primary schedule uh
ju just a bit ago we were talking about
it in the producers corner and if you're
not aware I do a patreon only producers
Corner every Monday and Friday an hour
before the show that's right if you go
join the $20
patreon uh with your with your Discord
email that's right you got to join the
Discord and patreon uh discord's free
patreon if you join the $20 tier with
your your Discord email then you can
join us every Monday and Friday morning
an hour before the show we call it the
producers Corner we were talking about
it the morning um and I pulled up the
Republican primary schedule this morning
and just to give you a little bit of an
idea I think this is really good to know
some of these things uh and maybe maybe
I'll cut some of this out and post it
later on on social media so you guys can
see the primary schedule so you can know
what the hell is going to go on and you
so you know why Donald Trump's going to
be the nominee here um January 15th is
the Iowa Republican caucus now any of
these primaries that you see on the list
um that have the word caucus on them
almost every single every one of those
is going to go for Trump because it's a
caucus um and they're going to make sure
they're going to make sure that those
caucus leaders are trumpers that's
that's how that's going to work um
caucuses are cool for primaries they're
really bad uh when you want to talk
about actual democracy because if you've
ever watched a caucus work it doesn't
it's not it's not so Democratic and it's
one person one vote it's a lot of
influencing out in the open uh and it's
a lot of affiliation that happens H you
know you've heard me talk about
affiliation where you know it's kind of
like you're in a group of people right
you're standing around in a party and
you got three dumb [__] that
can't do anything but you know talk
about Trump and how great he it would be
for him to be a dictator you know what I
mean they're like yeah it would be great
for him to be a dictator then he could
tell everyone to go [__] themselves he
could get rid of all the immigrants get
rid of all the brown and black people
and get rid of all the LG btq people at
the same time all those people that make
me feel uncomfortable get me all up my
feels they make my privilege hurt you
know you know those [__] you
know who I'm talking about but you're
standing a group of people in those
three [__] and everyone else is
gonna kind of be like well Jesus Christ
I don't want to piss this person off
because I really don't want to have more
of a conversation than I have to with
him so you kind of agree with them based
on affiliation you know what because
you're Affiliated in that group you're
in that group you're Affiliated at that
point so affiliation uh happens a lot in
caucuses so the affiliation vote is
probably going to go towards Trump so
let's talk about January 15th is Iowa
Republican caucus okay there's 40
delegates keep this in mind on the math
because I was listening to someone the
other day I was talking to him back and
forth on Twitter and they were trying to
tell me how Nikki Haley's gonna win the
primary in New Hampshire which is all
good and fine she's not going to but
even if she did I'm going to show you
how it's not going to pan out for her uh
in the Iowa caucus it's 40 delegates
likely Trump will take all those
delegates going into January
23rd so this is before the month ends
these are the two caucuses that are this
month is a republican caucus in Iowa and
the New Hampshire primary okay now these
are the two big ones and the reason why
is because they're the two to go first
it is why Ronda santis has been running
for president of Iowa and Chris Christie
can't stay out of New Hampshire same way
with Nikki Haley even though she's not
going to win um listen I could give you
a million reasons why Nikki Haley isn't
going to win but people were pointing it
out this morning in the producer scner
as well is that they're doing the Obama
thing with her like she's not from this
country she wasn't born here birth
certificate birth certificate birth
certificate as if I needed to tell you
that these birthers were still alive and
well in the Republican Party the same
way they were when Obama was President
or running for
president it's it's the same thing and
they're going to destroy her but you
know whatever you don't have to listen
to
me so that the New Hampshire primary is
on January 23rd that's 22 delegates all
right so between those two primaries
Iowa and New Hampshire it's
62 delegates it's a lot of delegates we
go into the Nevada Primary which doesn't
make a shit's bit of difference on J on
February 6 because Nevada actually
caucuses to decide their delegates which
they award 26 on the e8th Virginia
islands has four so that's not even on
the same February 8th so that's not even
H it's not even blip on the map the next
one is very important February 24th this
is why Nikki Haley is in the race
February 24th is South Carolina's
primary this is why Nikki Haley even is
a viable candidate in the primary and
the reason why big money donors are
handing money to Nikki Haley to run all
the way to February 24th to the South
Carolina primary and the reason why is
because South Carolina is Nikki Haley's
home state she was the governor she was
the governor of South
Carolina
now if you have any kind any kind of
notion that Nikki Haley is going to do
anything but lose her home state you are
just got you got brain worms okay I know
she was the governor and all that [__]
but it's South Carolina folks she's the
one that took the Battle Flag the
Confederate Battle
Flag down off the Capital Property
okay it's not going to play well in a
Republican primary these are the people
who carried the [__] Confederate flag
into the capital while they were trying
to overthrow our government okay same
[__] same MAA same
[__] all right now what is
important about the South Carolina
primary it is the biggest Award of
delegates to that point on February 24th
there are 50 50 delegates now from that
point from the South Carolina primary
when Nikki Haley lose loses to Grandpa
Hitler who wants to be a dictator in
South Carolina is definitely going to go
with the dictator thing definitely going
to go with it they're gonna like yeah
dictator pay you got it we're MAA man
we're fascist we're Nazis let's do the
dict taster thing uh so they're going to
do that really there's Michigan there's
Idaho um there's the Missouri caucus
which doesn't reward any delegates at
that point uh there's the DC one there's
the North Dakota which is 29 there's
some other ones built in there that's
got some pretty good uh delegate numbers
Trump is going to win all those okay
that brings us to March 5th super
Tuesday it's a big one that's the day
after the trial that everyone thinks is
going to happen that's going to get
punted okay so that's March 4th is the
North Dakota caucus and that's the day
that Trump won't go on trial
yet telling you what I mean it's not on
the official primary schedule here but
I'm gonna slide that one in I'm gonna
slide it in there just gonna slide that
in all right when we get to Super
Tuesday if Trump has won everything all
of it but maybe Nikki Haley wins New
Hampshire the 22 delegates folks it's
cooked it's already cooked this is why I
keep telling Trump is going to be the
nominee if you look at this schedule
there's no there's no there's no way
Chris Christie beats him there's no
Ronda santz is done because January
15th as soon as he loses Iowa because he
put all his chips in Iowa he's
done and when we get the super Tuesday
and Nikki Haley has not won one state
and even if she does win new Hampshire
she's only one one state it's
cooked you're not understanding how
primaries work in the Republican party
when they have an incumbent I know
you're like Tony Donald Trump isn't in
office yeah but they think he should be
they think he was cheated that's the
whole point that's the whole point of
his narrative that he lost and he should
be president and they stole it from him
is
incumbency incumbency is King it's King
it's King in these
primaries it is the reason why Donald
Trump will
win he's GNA be the
nominee he's GNA run as dictator I'm GNA
show you a [__] video that he posted
on fraud social today and you're gonna
go holy [__] my God what's wrong with
this [__] well what's wrong with
him is he knows his supporters want him
to be a dictator he knows it he knows it
that's why he's saying it he doesn't he
doesn't say [__] he doesn't
know he doesn't speak
qanon on accident it's on purpose you
know and speaking of
Obama we're just talking about Obama and
how they're o trying to Obama Nikki
Haley you remember when he was several
months ago he was calling Joe Biden
Obama and everyone's like oh he's lost
his mind he's lost his mind he doesn't
even know who the president is and I was
like that's not what's going on he's
speaking qinon and then months later
he's like yeah you guys are dumb I was
speaking qanon like he told us out loud
that's what he was
doing it's what he was doing listen I I
know I know it's [__] popular
again I know it's popular to cheer on
the 14th I know it's popular to to want
Nikki Haley to win and not Trump to be
the nominee I know it's popular to want
him to be a I ridden fool but none of
that [__] is real it's not it's popular
it feels
good gets all up in your feels and makes
you feel good but I it's not real no
it's not the trial's not going to happen
on March 4th they're not going to 14th
him they're
not I know you want it you want him to
be dementia ridden he's not because
here's the thing when they say Joe Biden
Joe Biden Joe has lost his mind but he's
some kind of secret [__] demon who
wants to control the world and he's
moving all these chips around so that he
can control the cabal and take over our
country or some weird
[__] it can't be both of those things
folks we can't sell the American people
that Donald Trump is some kind of
dementia ridden fool and then he's an
evil mastermind who wants to [__] be
a dictator and Institute project
2025 okay it's it's not going to be a
that's not going to sell it we can't
sell it like that trust me it's not
going to happen they'll go wait which is
it which is it just like when they say
the [__] about Biden we're like which is
it dummy so you got to get your
messaging and narrative straight and the
messaging of narrative is he's goingon
to be the nominee and we gotta [__]
beat him with democracy that's how we
[__] beat him and we can oh my god
when we when we when
we give a theoretical
punch in the mouth to these Nazis
because it can be all the way down the
ballot if we do our job correctly if we
do our job correctly it can be all the
way down the
ballot and that's what's most important
he's going to be the easiest one to beat
because it's going to be the most
obvious to the American people that he
is the biggest [__] [__] box who
wants to be a dictator and a king and
that is the most unamerican [__]
thing that has ever ever ever entered
into an election and into a political
race in this
country that's the easy one the hard
part is going to be to drive the vote to
get those down boutot races to make to
make the Speaker of the House someone
who's [__] competent insane and not a
white Christian nationalist to make sure
the Senate can get [__] [__] done to
get rid of these [__] insurrectionist
and these terrorists out of our [__]
governments everywhere regardless of
what government is County City your your
[__] road districts your school
boards it's enough of this
[__] it's enough of this unamerican
manga fascist nazi [__] and it's going
to take a long time to do it but we have
to send a [__] message and the
message has to be you can't [__] with us
because we are the people it is our
democracy it is our constitutional
republic and we get to vote who [__]
represents us that's how it works [__]
so stand back and standby pro-democracy
Coalition that's right stand back and
stand by because the primaries are about
to kick off and the election season is
about to start and it is going to be
awesome trust me it's going to be a
great one and we're going to be able to
form the narrative and the reason why is
cu they can't stop themselves from
showing their fash don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
paron blanket I've got you covered paron
blanket specifically Works to make you
feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
paron blanket will protect you too paron
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
100% made in the USA don't delay and get
your pardon blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast it's Friday January 5th tomorrow
3 years since Grandpa Hitler's two
attempt does it seem like 3
years
can't wait till we get to the 20 years
and I get to say it's been 20 years
since Grandpa Hitler triying to
overthrow the government of the United
States and then we kicked his ass in
2022 and kicked his ass again in 2024
maybe in 2026 and 2028 hell I don't
know I I mean I'm cheering for the
Republicans to nominate him in 2024
because he is going to it is GNA be so
[__] delicious to beat him do you
know how do you know how oh my god do
you know how you know how [__] much
energy you're gonna have when that
[__]
loses because we did our job oh my
God it is just gonna fire you the [__]
up do you remember
um 911 September 11th 2001 there was a
some PL
that kind of terrorist flew into some
buildings killed several thousands
Americans we went to war for two decades
over that dumb [__] do you remember the
night that Barack Obama came out of the
White House and he come down that
[__] hallway with the red carpet with
the
podium he leaned into the microphone and
said we got him we got aama Bin Laden we
got that [__] and the entire
yeah what
like the entire country it's like one
big hurah right when we beat Donald
Trump they're going to be people dancing
in the [__]
streets I'm telling you it's gonna
happen they're going to be dancing in
the [__]
streets because this country is not Maga
it's not they're really [__] loud and
obnoxious so it feels sometimes like on
the daily that these [__] are
everywhere
but they're not they're just loud
they're just [__] and that's why we
need to get louder that's why that's why
we need to be louder and again Trump
isn't the disease he's the symptom of it
so we've got a long we've got a long
ways to go because white Christian
nationalism and fascism Has Come Out
Underneath from its Rock and we need to
send it back there but it's going to
take a while so that's why I want to
show you a few more Clips today this is
um some I don't know who the hell this
is we're going to get back to the uh the
caucus I want to show you that schedule
a little bit before we go to bonehead of
the week but I want to show you some
clips here and we're going to do
bonehead of the week with Gabe Sanchez
actually let me check in on it let me
check in on bonee head of the week Bon
head of the week okay um here is um I
think his name is Lance Wu I don't know
who this guy is he's a white Christian
nationalist he's a Trumper this is on
some weird ass [__] right-wing
Christian [__] thing I don't know what
the [__] is going on here um who this
guy is looks like he's had a [__] ton of
Botox and a [__] ton of gender
reconfirming surgery with the hair plugs
but let's let's try it out let's see
what this guy has to say about what he
thinks America is and isn't the media on
the left is going to try to label us as
Christian nationalists whoa whoa whoa
easy easy easy on the media
talk and on the left talk
[__] cuz he wants to talk about the
main M Street they are not on the left
the mainstream media is not liberal
media I'm liberal media [__] get it
straight and I don't call you a
Christian nationalist [__] that
is not what I call you I call you a
white Christian nationalist okay get it
[__] straight you are a white
Christian nationalist because you are a
[__] fascist and you are a Nazi okay
got it it's white Christian nationalist
get it right continue
they're they're doing that to smear us
but the reality is I think we're far
more dangerous than Christian
nationalists we're whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa what did you did you hear what
did you hear what this guy just said
he's like they're trying to smear us but
call us Christian nationalist again he's
getting it wrong it's white Christian
nationalist I don't know if you know
that like um that's why I say that it's
intentional like it's again I'm trying
I'm trying to message right and when you
when you say Christian nationalist you
don't really get at the heart of what it
means do you know what I mean do you
know what I mean when you say white in
front of it when you're intending that
hey not only is it a is there they're
Theocratic
fascist but they're racist they're
bigots and they're gonna try to kill
everyone who's not white got it
you got you got it you got it that's
that's what they're going to try to do
that's why you call them white Christian
nationalists it takes a little more
energy to say the word but it's it's
it's purposeful and it's and it's
critical that you you say it correctly
white Christian nationalist but he says
he's they're more dangerous he says
they're more dangerous than than white
or than than than Christian nationalist
okay well let's let's go go with that
let's go with that there Adolf let's
let's hear how you're more dangerous
than Christian nationalist white
Christian nationalist we're Christian
internationalist I
[Laughter]
think so they're globalist now what the
[__] are you talking what the f do these
people listen to anything they say
before they say it out loud what in the
actual
[__] did he get in front of a mirror and
try this out before he said it out loud
what the [__] he's like we're we're not
we're not white Christian nationalists
we're much more dangerous we're much
more dangerous than white Christian
nationalist we're white Christian
internationalist okay explain how you're
globalist you guys are always talking
about how [__] liberals or globalists
and [__] what huh okay explain it to me
explain now you're an internationalist
let's hear it Jesus is Lord of every
nation and he's been given a authority
over Heaven and Earth and this move of
God Is Going Global this
year it's going global baby they're
they're white Christian go
globalist I can't make this [__] up like
I could I couldn't I couldn't even come
up with this [__] on my own like if I
sat around like what is the dumbest
thing they could possibly say what is it
what's the what's the dumbest thing
what's the dumbest thing
it would be it would sound something
like that I mean there's a lot more
Dumber things there really is um I'm G
to show you one here this is [__]
crazy speaking of white Christian
nationalist are white Christian
globalist they're white Christian
globalist we're not Christian
nationalists we're white Christian
globalist okay like the global blood
sucking cabal or something is that what
you're talking about because that's what
it feels like you're saying remember
Bill Cook the other day I showed you
Bill Cook he's a he's a white Christian
nationalist he's a [__] Nazi remember
he was saying about God and how how how
he wanted to make sure that every single
person in this country believe the God
that he believes that's what he believes
right he also wants to kill FBI agents
that don't believe in God I'm not
kidding I'm I'm I'm not kidding you he
wants to kill he wants to alive FBI
agents who don't believe in his god
listen and so I want to say to my
friends in the
FBI keep doing
it because death is about to execute a
no knock warrant on you on you whoa whoa
what what what is the FBI
lisening huh what what' you say he said
he wants to un alive FBI agents now he's
talking about what he's what he's what
he's talking about here is he's talking
about FBI agents arresting people
involved in the January 6 Insurrection
and he's saying we see you we see you
arresting these insurrectionist charging
them putting in jail for the federal
crimes that they committed and they've
been indicted by grand juries and and
found guilty from juries of their peers
or they pled guilty in the court of law
so they took responsibility for their
actions you know whatever you want
however you want to put it but he's te
he's saying that he wants to un alive
he wants to kill death death will visit
you with a no knock warrant to FBI
agents that's what the [__] he's saying
listen to this listen he's going to
invade your domicile this body and take
you out of it when he does You're Gonna
Stand before
God so God is GNA direct death to come
un alive you so you can stand before him
in
judgment because you arrested people and
did your job
you know like Law and Order type stuff
you know what I mean that kind of stuff
all right keep go keep going keep keep
with the felonies
here look at his shirt I don't know
what's worse him threatening the FBI or
this [__] shirt look at it the the
[__] American flag and the
eagle what the are dude come on man just
get a regular sh shirt man you're you're
you're talking about [__] unal
living agents of the federal government
under the flag of which you're you're
[__] wearing on your shirt for
presidents who have sworn an oath to
that same country the same oath that
those FBI agents take to uphold the laws
that some of those President signed into
law under the banner of the flag that
you have on your shirt these people are
so lost in the irony of this it's not
even funny but go keep going keep going
with the [__] felony threats keep
going and it's it's it's not going to be
pleasant you're going to see the love of
God but it's only going to be for a
fleeting
second the love of God the love of God
man it's the love of God that's what it
is now I know I'm laughing and I'm
making a joke and mocking them but folks
this is Maga
101 this is what is coming to your
[__] doorstep
you I I told you a story um a couple
weeks ago about a friend I was talking
to and he he made a joke about he would
vote for RFK instead of Biden as a joke
and I said don't do that vote for Trump
please for the sake of you and your
family don't do that do not vote for RFK
as a joke so you can make a joke because
if Trump wins I want you to be on the
rolls for Trump and he said why why do
you want me to vote for Trump if Trump
wins I said because when they come
around with the voting roles to see who
you voted for and they come to your
house and they drag you and your family
out the front yard to kill you to un
alive you so you can go see the love of
God for only a second a fleeting
second I want to make sure you voted for
the right person so they don't kill you
and your
family folks they're saying it on stage
they're preaching it to their [__]
minions they're they're they're pumping
this [__] into the brains of the
delusion in this country it the
messaging is cascading out so much so
that Grandpa Hitler wants to be the
dictator and he knows they want to be
the dictator and this is the reason why
this is the disease folks I'm showing
you the disease Trump is only the
symptom of this
disease don't be tricked by the noise
don't be tricked by it by the grifting
ass noise and that's what it is it's
grifting ass noise I hate to say it some
of them are my friends but it's grifting
ass noise is what it is it's grifting
ass noise they're getting you to pay
attention to the [__] they say so they
can sell you an
ad or or get you to get you to watch the
YouTube channel so it'll [__] play an
ad my Channel's not monetized on YouTube
it hasn't been for a long time because
they [__] wouldn't monetize me
Facebook took my monetization away when
they [__] suspended me for 30 days
from live from live broadcasting the
only place that I'm monetize on his
twitch and I'm waiting for that to be
stripped away from
me you are what powers this microphone
You by you being here you being a
patreon member and keeping me going keep
the [__] lights and the internet
going all the people that contribute to
this show with their hard-earned [__]
energy and time the mods um skip our our
clip Master Derek the mean General Ty
the pr the pr Godus right Gabe Sanchez
all the time that he's put in
this and small rat baby in the
laboratory cooking cooking up cooking up
the Spells against fascism
right don't listen to the grifting ass
noise that's what I was trying to tell
you yesterday because they're not going
to pay attention to this [__] and show
you what the [__]
diseases because that's how we really
that's how we really get rid of these
[__] that's how we really get
rid of them in our public life that's
how we get rid of their
fod is we ostracize them we put them
back underneath their rocks where they
[__] belong because you can't get rid
of an
idea you can't that's the problem with
project
2025 they've let that cat out of the bag
and it's out you can't stuff it back in
you're not going to get it back in
there ideas don't
die the only thing you can do is to have
a better one to convince someone that
that idea [__]
sucks so have good ideas that's what
I've been telling you about
ideology and boy you guys get it you
guys get it CU you're here every day
even people even people who are mad at
me for saying some of the [__] I'm
saying they're starting to get it and
and some people I I I want to point out
a you some people have been sending
support saying hey Tony I don't get in
the chat and I'm not always in the chat
and I'm not always but I support you and
I hear what you're saying uh Lori is one
of them uh there's a few others Jenny
um
natsir um who else I had a few people
join patreon and send me great messages
and I want to tell you that all that
means the most to
me but what matters most is you're here
listening rather you [__] love it or
you [__] hate it because let me tell
you something this is not a reality that
you want with this guy
listen God's finished with you he will
he will send you to your Eternal
destination Eternal
heal
God God God God God this God that Hitler
this Hitler that dictator this dictator
that these people are primed American
Christianity is primed for this now I'm
not going to say all Christians in this
country are bad because they're not but
the ones that aren't actually Christian
the white Christian nationalists because
they're not Christian they're not
following the [__] book they're not
even reading the [__] book it seems
really if you want to know the God's
honest
truth but it's the disease that is
rotting the brains of these morons that
are
pre their preconstructed bias is to have
one person who can fix everything for
them you just pray to that one
[__] you just give that one
[__] your attention and he'll
fix all your
problems only he can fix it right am I
right
am the
right that's what their belief
is that's how their worldview is because
it's pumped into their brains over and
over and over all the
time and it's really easy for them to
believe this
stuff super easy for them to believe
this
stuff that's that's what I I try to tell
you is that okay the the all the all the
[__]
the Trump crack right the Trump crack
with the with the videos and the
feel-good stuff about how he it's going
to be like this and it's gonna be like
that and it's not going to be it's not
it's not that's all [__] that's all
grifting noise that's all [__] Trump
crack it's Trump crack to get you H
hooked and addicted to keep you watching
to keep you clicking and listen those
people out there that are selling the
Trump crack with the grift they're an
important part of our [__] messaging
block and we need to get them on board
with the real [__] message the real
[__] narrative not the grifting ass
[__] that is going on [__] that [__] the
Trump
crack we got to get him on board and we
got to get the pro-democracy Coalition
in one resounding
voice and I know a lot of people like we
can do two things at once no we should
not we should not do two things at once
we should only do one [__]
thing one thing and one thing only and
that is beat fascism
it's going to be like this for a while
too like this election probably 2026
probably 2028 this is still going to be
our
mission right it's gonna take a while to
not only get these people to crawl back
underneath their rocks but get them the
[__] out of our goddamn
governments and until we really get this
rotten disease out of our [__]
governments this manga [__] isn't going
to
quit it's not going to end with [__]
Grandpa Hitler it
won't Jesus Christ you Hitler the real
one the OG Hitler is dead he's been
dead and they're still running around
with signed copies of Mind comp bragging
about how they're going to take over the
[__] world and kill everyone who
doesn't look like them they're still
doing it because ideas don't
die they only crawl under
rocks that's
it that's
it we have to have a message that is
against that
idea that's it period not not a message
built on something that isn't going to
happen or couldn't happen maybe it won't
maybe it will maybe it won't who
knows there's one thing for [__]
certain one [__] thing for
certain
the fash are gonna
fash that's for [__]
certain you can count on that
[__] no matter how much power they do or
don't have no M no matter how much
influence they do or don't
have no matter how much money whether
they're they're in Congress they're not
they they have state governments County
governments no matter what even if
they're under their rocks you can guar
God God damn te the fash is g to
fash you're not going to get rid of
that you're only you're only going to
move on past having it in your daily
[__] life where they're [__]
trying to trying to [__] criminalize
women's pregnancies where they're trying
to ban women's privacy in a [__]
doctor's office where they're trying to
make it to where women can't vote
because they want to do that next where
they're taking away parental rights from
people who have children trans lgbtq
children they want to ostracize those
people those Americans from our society
because they're uncomfortable with
them and that doesn't stop there it
doesn't stop
there it is so important that we see
this
clearly that is the disease
Trump is just the wart on our ass
because we have this
disease and just because we cut off the
wart doesn't mean one won't grow
back we have to get this disease into
remission we have to get them out of our
governments we have to get them in a
position where the American people will
reject their
ideas holy
fully that is how we
win ideology
ideas narrative messaging that is how we
we don't win our democracy in a [__]
courtroom that is not where we win our
democracy back
folks civil or criminal we don't win our
democracy in a [__]
courtroom we win it with the people who
matter
Americans people who are in this [__]
country people who go to work every
[__] day and don't have enough
[__] time to pay attention to every
single political story Jesus Christ we
can't even muster up enough [__]
courage to talk about how a goddamn
child got killed by another [__]
child and Parry [__] Iowa because
they just can't help but make sure that
people can [__] gun down children in
a goddamn
school and you want to talk about court
motions you want to talk about one
[__]
huh taking one [__] off ballots
what the [__] are you talking about we
have much more big problems to get
to but if we don't if we do not address
the disease the wart will continue to
grow they'll pop up all kinds of
places so pay attention to what is
matters and what's important I know most
the people here do because you're every
you're here every [__] day regardless
if you agree with every [__] last
thing I say which you shouldn't you
shouldn't agree with every [__] word
that comes out of my mouth Howell a lot
of people don't like my language they
[__] hate my language if you want to
be completely honest they [__] hate
it they [__] hate that I cuss they
wish I didn't cuss there's a lot of
people wish I didn't swear say cursed
words the naughty
language but it's me that's
authentically me and if I didn't then it
wouldn't be authentically me and I would
be selling you something that's not real
I would be tricking you into something
that's not authentic
I believe in this country I believe in
our constitution I believe in our
democracy I believe in our institutions
even as how failed they are and and and
the stains of the history of our
institutions and our democracy and our
society the the absolute gross stains
that we have but we get better and we
get better and we get better and the
reason why is because if we put our
faith into people into the American
people the people who are here I don't
care if you're documented or
undocumented this country is people
that's what this country is it's not a
few white land owners it's not a few
people who want to push their [__]
fascist religious beliefs on us and they
sell it up as something that Jesus said
and it ain't anything Jesus [__]
said I believe in the American
people because what is America without
the people huh what is our society what
is our country what does it matter what
the Constitution says without we the
people and I'm sick and tired of them
taking those those foundations and
principles of our [__] democracy and
bastardizing them for
fascism [__] I would be loud and proud
to where a shirt that said we the people
and we the
Liberals because that's the [__]
truth that's why our society is the way
it is it's the reason why we live it's
the reason why we live in the
communities that we live in is
liberalism not conservatism not
fascism if that was the case they
wouldn't be talking about how now they
want a dictator how we haven't had a
dictator this whole time but now we want
one okay know it see it be
it let me show you another let me show
you another vi vi vi here um speaking of
the shooting in in Perry
Iowa oh boy um again just another
senseless tragedy because uh with a
sixth grader being killed and five
others being uh um injured by a
17-year-old boy another child getting a
gun because we we just and apparently
had an explosive device a shotgun a
handgun all because we have an obsession
about letting [__] people just
willy-nilly getting guns and taking them
anywhere they want having them anyhow
they want because my granddaddy or some
dumb [__] like that you know it says
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
that's what it says that's what we said
that's what we declared life liberty in
the pursuit of
happiness where in those words life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness is
children having to hide from someone who
the government lets who politicians let
Who We the People let because we elect
these [__] hide hide to be
[__] slaughtered huh where CU that's
going to be the right- wings narrative
oh it wasn't it wasn't an a 15
dummy I want an air what the [__] does
that matter you're not even listening to
what the [__] we're
saying we're saying ban assault rifles
but we're also talking about background
checks we're talking about waiting
periods we're talking about people who
don't lock up their [__] weapons well
enough for their 17-year-old kids to get
a hold of them and go kill other
children you stupid
[__] we're talking about accountability
and responsibility here you know
sometimes would be considered
conservative principles that's all we're
talking about here you dumb
[__] we're not talking about an
absolute ban on guns I mean hey you make
it easy for that narrative to take
hold you make that narrative easy for
for people to say out loud but that's
not what we're talking
about there are some people in this
country I'm sure that would wish that we
got rid of the Second Amendment
altogether and again you're not helping
out when when iist like poop mat Ron
when he's responding to this this
tragedy in Perry Iowa which the guy has
been running for president of Iowa for
the last year poop Matt Ron here has
been running for the president of Iowa
he's spent more [__] time in Iowa in
the last year then he and he do even
know Florida anymore he probably don't
even know what the beaches of Florida
feel like the sand on his feet feels
like anymore he's been in Iowa for so
goddamn
long
and in Perry Iowa a 17-year-old boy
kills young children in a
school because [__] boxes like this say
dumb [__] like this and and you as you
mentioned are a parent what can you say
to Iowa parents right now who who are
afraid who are watching this news um you
know these school shootings keep
happening who are worried about sending
their kids to Public Schools well well
look I mean you know we we obviously you
know have a responsibility to create
safe environments um federal government
is probably not going to be leading that
effort I think it is more of a local and
State issue um but we've shown how it's
done in Florida uh the things that we've
done have been very very effective uh
but we also just have to look at for
whatever reason uh there are people in
our society that really get a kick out
of doing this um oh they really get a
kick out of doing this oh yeah yeah they
get a kick out of so hey hey here's an
idea I I don't know just one idea maybe
this will help you poop ma Ron [__]
meatball maybe this will help you out
huh maybe this will help you one idea
let's make sure we just don't [__]
willy-nilly give everyone guns then how
about that huh since we know since you
are so sure that there's people in
society that get their [__] rocks off
by going and killing people with guns
maybe we shouldn't
um just give anyone and everyone [__]
guns I don't know it feels like to me
the part of the equation that is
actually the problem is the gun because
if they get their rocks off on doing
this killing people with a gun and we
don't we don't give them a gun would
just let them get a gun whenever they
want yeah yeah [__] you want to go kill
people hell we'll give you a gun we're
Republican Pew Second
Amendment maybe that's what you should
do maybe just a [__] idea
huh and yeah you're not going to stop
every [__] one of them we're not
saying that you're going to stop every
one of them we're not dumb as dog [__]
like
you we know we know any measure that we
take with guns is not going to stop gun
violence totally
100% but what about the [__] sixth
grader in Perry
Iowa what about the five other people
that were shot and
killed what about the 17-year-old child
that
now destroy their [__] life too
because you just had to make sure that
people who get their rocks off doing
this type of stuff get the guns to do
it oh that's right oh that's right
that's right you take blood money from
the
NRA I forgot I forgot this isn't about
the I I forgot it's not about life it's
not about life it's not about the
children it's not about laws hell it's
not even really about the guns if you
get right down to it is it Ron is it
Poop
Map the real problem is you just
wouldn't get enough [__]
money you just wouldn't get the money
that you
need to pump the fascism into our
governments the way that you want to
without that [__] blood
money [__] poop maon [__] that guy
you know what that is one good thing
that Trump did I'm going to give him
credit here no I'm serious I'm I'm dead
serious that is one good thing that
Trump did for our
country don't don't get me wrong here
just bear with me bear with me that's
one good thing that Trump did with for
our country he [__] destroyed Ronda
sanz's political career I'm excited
about that nothing makes me more
excited than him destroying Ronda sanz's
career
now he's done a lot of bad [__] but did
you see uh speaking of bad [__] did you
see uh alen have it on Fox news last
night she's like hey Brett Kavanaugh
that's a really nice Supreme Court
Justice seat you got there it would be
ashamed if something happened to it I'm
not kidding you no I mean she didn't say
that but pretty much you know what I
mean like the old uh oh those are nice
kneecaps it'd be a shame to something
happened to
him oh she did it yeah here it is here
it is on Fox knes watch you I think it
should be a slam dunk in the Supreme
Court I have faith in them you know
people like um Kavanagh who the
president fought for who the president
went through held to get into place
he'll step up those people will step up
not because they're Pro Trump but
because because they're Pro law because
they're pro- fairness and the law on
this is very
clear
that's that's a nice Supreme Court
Justice seat you got there be ashamed if
something happened to it like when I
become the dict tasor oh boy you just
might end up on a list and he's really
already on a list you see that these
fascists already have a list I'm gonna
prove it to you watch they they already
have a list going of who they're GNA
kill that's right there's already a kill
list
going for the fascist
don't believe me watch when she tries to
come up with kavanagh's name watch watch
when she does it it is right right there
okay watch when she does it watch them
you know people like um Kavanagh who the
people like um I don't know let me go to
my kill list let me go to the kill list
I mean potential possible geez we
wouldn't want to do it if we didn't have
to let me go to that list let me look at
it here let me take a glance here what
people like people like people like who
Kavanaugh I you [__] think I'm cra
listen no one else is gonna tell you
that [__] there ain't a [__]
commentator out there that is going to
show you this clip and gonna [__]
show you that and say it not one of them
they got a [__] list folks she's
carried around a goddamn list of
people
watch don't believe me watch you know
people like um Kavanagh who
the people like um Kavanaugh H that's
just one of the names on my list I got
here that that Grandpa Hitler gave me to
threaten I mean I got a whole list of
[__] people to threaten on Fox news
that Grandpa Hitler gave me because you
know they're poisoning the blood they're
Vermin you know what I
mean you know what I mean
I mean we got a Vermin list going or a
possible Vermin list going if they don't
do what they're supposed to do
right you don't I'm serious you don't
sometimes feels like that people like
Tony stop saying that stuff about the
14th why why you're you're clearly not
saying the stakes here that's why we
need to do the 14th thing yeah that's a
long shot and here's why it's a long
shot they got a list going and if you
don't think if you don't think the
people on the list that are on their
side because that's how fascism works
baby I don't know if you know that I
don't know if you've studied it but
that's how [__] Nazism
Works they kill the denters on their
side
first first they
go
watch watch the list you know people
like um Kavanaugh who
the let me check my to threaten
list [__] true how did how would she
not know kavanagh's
name she had to go to the
list and who do you think gave her that
list who do you think it
was I know who it
was and if you don't think that some of
this stuff um can be reality then you're
dreaming you're not really aware of when
authoritarianism and fascism absolutely
breaks up and kills a democracy but 11
films has done a video and we're almost
there for
um uh the um we're almost there for
bonehead of the week um but I I want to
show you a a it's a couple minutes long
it's a video that 11 films has done has
put out uh and it it and it gives you a
a really kind of good insight into what
it could look like now it won't look
like this because we're gonna smash his
ass you know what I mean we're gonna
[__] smash the fash here we're gonna
punch the Nazis with our ballots do you
see what I mean we're gonna put the
ballot boxing gloves on and really give
them a good smashing if you know what I
mean it's going to be it's going to be
fantastic
and it's going to be a resounding win
it's going to be mountains of votes
piled on top of these
idiots it really will
be and and we're going to be cheering in
the streets it's going to be exciting
it's going to give our democracy new
energy just like just like 2020 gave us
new energy 2022 2023 is given us new
energy New
Hope For What Western liberal democracy
when the people participate when the
people
engage when they know the real issues
that matter before them so that they can
and govern the way that they
should but this is a glimpse into
reality if we don't do our
job I love this guy he says you're not
going to be a dictator are you I said no
no no other than day
one as my first order of business I
hereby declare
martial
law citizens of the new
America here are today's
announcements supreme leader Donald
Trump proclaims the 4th of July will no
longer be celebrated as Independence
Day in honor of our 2021 Patriots
January 6th will now be recognized as
our great nation's
birthday all citizens are required to
participate in quadrant festivities
failure to do so will be met with harsh
punishment and immediate incarceration
in your local detention Camp I'm tired
of this separation of church and state
junk effective immediately all children
are now considered spiritual soldiers of
Maga regardless of rape incest or health
of the woman abortion is now illegal
anyone caught providing or receiving an
abortion will be charged with murder do
you believe in punishment for abortion
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form due to previous liberal
indoctrination all schools are hereby
closed all citizens must participate in
their Quadrant Book elimination
celebration
festivity failure to do so will be met
with harsh punishment and immediate
incarceration in your local detention
Camp all migrants refugees and dreamers
are now considered enemies of the new
America and will be rounded up
incarcerated and deported immediately
they're poisoning the blood of our
country that's what they've done we will
root out the radical left thugs that
live like Vermin verman verman your
curfew and freedom to travel will be
determined by your quadrant verman
surveillance system score the fman
surveillance system has proven to be
invaluable in detecting and squashing
liberal Uprising all citizens must
continue to report any Progressive or
liberal activity failure to do so will
be met with harsh punishment and
immediate incarceration at your local
detention
Camp your unwavering loyalty to supreme
leader Donald Trump is mandatory and
essential in keeping the new America
great
[Music]
forever there you have it that is
Trump's new
America don't believe it if you don't
want I mean that's cool whatever you
want to do I mean that's all right if
you don't want to believe that that's
how dictatorship that's how when
democracies fall and autocracies take
them
over that's the kind of [__] that
happens regardless of what you want or
what you think is fuzzy and
warm about your way of life or your
lifestyle or how it just it just happens
to happen it just happens to happen it's
just a thing that happens it's just it's
just there democracy and our way of life
and the McDonald's is down the road the
schools there you know the elementary
schools there the middle school's over
there high schools over there we got
colleges in the towns up north they're
really great the shopping mall or the
outlet
mall the Starbucks oh man they're there
too oh boy I can go get me a a frate
latte whatever the [__] it is that you
get
it won't just be there that's the
point when autocracy takes cold it
changes an entire
nation I don't know if you know know
this but tomorrow's going to mark three
years since the only coup
attempt on the office of the presidency
of the United States the only one the
only one that was a violent coup
attempt and it it changed our country
forever it will never go back to being
the same ever just like 911 changes
Oklahoma City Bombing
changes the Gulf War Vietnam War second
world
war Korean
war that stuff changes a nation civil
rights the pandemic the AIDS epidemic in
the 80s and the 90s
the Supreme Court deciding that gay
marriage was legal all across the land
you don't think these things change our
nation these are pivotal moments that
make us who we are good and bad we
fought a whole War a whole war of about
slavery about white people owning black
people in this
country it changed our [__] Nation
sometimes it's not
good but we get to make that
decision it's us we get to make the
decision rather the
change is good or
bad and that's that's all that's all we
have to
do is make sure we stay grounded in the
principles of
democracy no matter what our ideology is
and what the differences in our idea
ideologies are because no one's ideas
are exactly the same we are not carbon
copies of each other there is
individualism it does
exist and we have freedoms to protect
it and we have rights that the
constitution grants us to protect that
Liberty of our individualism
but we are a fabric of a society and we
must live that
way it is essential that we recognize
every single person that is in this
country no matter their dumb ideas I've
told you time and time again I do not
have a
problem with Nazis having the right to
go to a overpass in
Florida and Hile Ronda santis and
support him as a
Nazi that is their freedom now they
can't cross a certain line because we
all know that there's not absolute
freedom of speech I mean not unless you
talk to Elon Musk I mean unless he fires
people from SpaceX for speaking out
against him you know freedom of
speech but there is no absolute freedom
of
speech and also there is consequences
for every single piece of your speech
all of it all the crazy [__] I showed
you today about these white Christian
nationalists just a few clips that
you're like Jesus [__] Christ that's
crazy what these people want and then I
show you a postulation of what it could
be possible if if Trump does become the
dictator of the United States and you're
like godamn this is [__]
nuts there's consequences for all that
speech all of of
it but only if we make them consequences
you know what I
mean only if we make them
consequences that's
it so let's give them the consequence
and send them [__]
packing let's do that Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us in just a few minutes I
promise the guy with the last name
Sanchez is going to
be
here he will be here uh and we're going
to do bonehead of the year you know who
won we had a few of them on there um and
a lot of it's goingon to play in today's
um to to today's title about the uh the
Chinese bribes that Trump and his son
took so there is that um but I want to
show you something I told you I'd show
you Fox News is really excited they're
really excited about Brandon's
accomplishments here's Stuart vanney on
Fox Business
216,000 jobs added to the economy last
month the unemployment rate finished the
year unchanged at 3.7% now put it all
together well damn it hang on hang on a
second buttons here let's let's let's
try it again let's try it again let's go
Brandon let's go Brandon
216,000 jobs added to the economy last
month the unemployment rate finished the
year unchanged at 3.7% now put it all
together and I'll call that a strong
report 26 he call it a strong
[Laughter]
report oh my God I mean breaking news
Fox Business loves Brandon's e economic
accomplishments is't that something a
that something that um the
um the nonfarm payroll increased 26,000
workers keeping the unemployment rate
and an alltime low while while
while the stock market is at an all-time
high I don't know here's another one
here see an inake on it let's see this
just in the final jobs report of 2023
showing the economy added
216,000 and
jobs whoa [__] how are we going to spin
the narrative that Brandon is unpopular
now oh my God somebody hurry get a poll
showing that how this is bad for
Biden that's what CNN's doing you know
what I mean you know what I mean I'm
serious that's what CN they're like
they're like oh [__] this is not what we
want we don't want to tell our audience
how great Brandon is hurry quick get a
poll saying how unpopular the guy
who has the economic policy that the
economy created 216,000 jobs please
hurry go run make a poll lie whatever
you have to
do I don't know I don't know maybe tell
them you got a black friend I don't know
that's a horrible transition but what do
you want from me what do you want from
me um I'm trying to show you some clips
here before we get the Bon head of the
week here is Nikki Haley saying she's
got a black friend I don't I don't get
to make this stuff up I know you might
be mad at me but I don't get to make
this stuff up I just I [__] play it
in commentative for you you're [__]
paying attention because everyone's like
hey Nikki Haley's gonna win Nikki
Haley's gonna win someone was telling me
that on Twitter and they follow me and
I'm sure they watch the show possibly
maybe they pay attention to my Twitter
account to some degree because they
commented on a post I made
um and they well they're just so sure
that Nikki Haley's gonna win New
Hampshire which won't make a shit's bit
of difference let me show you this here
let me do this I told you I'd show you
the um the primary schedule here here it
is here is um this is the Republican
caucus schedule I'll zoom out here so
you can kind of see because this is the
New York Times you just all you got to
do is just Google Republican primary
schedule and you you'll get this link
but it's the New York Times link now I'm
not advocating for the New York Times
it's just you know I'm able to go to the
website and show you this [__] on the
show so bear with me all right January
15th that's the that's the next one the
next election is January 15th it's the
Iowa Republican caucus it's the one that
Nikki Haley and the clip that I'm about
to show you um this one here this clip
here I'm about to show you this clip of
her saying that she has a black friend
and Iowa I'm not kidding that's what she
said I don't make this [__] up again um
but that's the oh Iowa Republican caucus
and then January 23rd is the is the New
Hampshire primary New Hampshire New
Hampshire New Hampshire is always here
in Missouri New Hampshire uh it's the
primary there is January 23rd now if you
believe polls which you shouldn't um
you'll believe that Trump is up in the
pole and Nikki Haley is trailing him by
a uh it's a huge margin and she's
virtually tied in the poll with Ronda
santz but you don't need to go look at
those polls you don't need to go look at
those plls because they're full of [__]
number one number two I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna tell you what's gonna happen
okay I'm just gonna tell you what's
gonna happen Trump's gonna win the New
Hampshire primary is what he's gonna do
Trump is gonna win that New Hampshire
primary and get 22 delegates to go to
the Republican National Convention
speaking speaking of going somewhere or
getting somewhere or I don't know having
a car or something like that
uh gab Sanchez the guy with the last
name
Sanchez Sanchez how's it going you got a
new car right here I finally got a new
car that's [__] exciting whatever
well here's what I'll tell you I'm I'm
talking about the primaries oh so you
can't hear me no I can hear you I I said
my my headphones weren't working oh how
can you hear me if you ain't got your
headphones in it's coming on my computer
oh but I want to avoid any Echo you know
yeah well you know we we would we would
appreciate if you would get your
equipment um going over there I thought
I thought it was charged man thought it
was
Char I'm over I'm over here like I woke
up this morning feeling like complete
dog [__] yeah yeah what was I was afraid
I was like oh [__] do I have Co but I
tested I'm negative so did you did you
run out of fizzy water is that what it
was did you yeah I mean that's my fuel
man that's here I'll say I'll say this
this is I'm sorry I'm sorry I've I've
given a lot of Jabs so far look at that
he's he's even got a is that a teabag
are you teabagging over
there are you teabagging perfect angel
oh my
God oh my God so you haven't been here
in a while so I'm sorry with the
holidays and everything I just I you
know I gotta give some Jabs at you I I
like I like you know I like the I like
the you but yeah my uh I did get I did
get a car back oh okay well sorry sorry
well here we already know what happened
right I gave everyone the update last
year which is like they found the car
but it was it was done right they didn't
[__] in it like you thought yes they did
not I was hoping I was hoping they would
[__] that's what but they they happened
to uh they trash it a little bit not a
lot um anyway long story short um I had
to deal with the they gave me a car at
one point and then I had to exchange it
and then they're like well the only cars
that we have are electric cars so then I
had to get this electric Chevy bolt
which I will say
this very smooth it's a very what are
you some kind of libtard you driving
around in an EV what what what is this
but but hold on this is my I it's not
that look it's a smooth driving car
steering's great you know Cycles through
it's
great the biggest problem is the
charging it takes [__] forever and
also wait wait you have to charge an
electric vehicle I know man it's crazy
but here's the
thing planning planning to to go and
charge the car is such a hassle and it's
not just like oh I have to you know
charge the car and wait for it because
like I can you know I can spend time
writing a script for what was that or
like you know Tweeting or something like
I can I can SP or I can go run an erand
or whatever it's the people that are
also charging who go around and go oh
how much time you got left on that
charge over there how long you been here
huh how long like they're like [__]
Hawks surrounding prey they're like
flies on [__] they are circling you
expecting you to be like let's go when
are you done I want to ask I wan to ask
I W to ask why are you're charging do
any of these [__] Drive the Cyber
truck where they I have not seen one
cyber truck in
the I have not seen has anyone seen
has anyone seen a cyber truck in public
at this point only the only time I've
seen a cyber truck in the public is
another person documenting they found a
cyber truck in the public and then I'm
watching I watched this couple who was
at a charging a Tesla charging station
and they saw the Cyber truck roll up and
the thing's a [__] boat it's like 20
point turn just to back up into the
stall so they can plug it in and charge
it and then the guy just covered it up
and left and they're like oh and the
people that were the couple that was
watching was like oh you got a cyber
truck that's so so cool and they're like
talking about how they want one and
stuff and the guy who's driving the
Cyber truck not interested so I don't
know if people who have cyber trucks now
were
like instantly just kind of
um they're already like kind of stunted
in terms of the the public perception of
it so they're like oh I don't want to
deal with anyone because you guys are
GNA make fun of me or if it's because
the guy is just like you know Tesla
owners are just [__] I have no idea
oh we're definitely goingon to make fun
of them for sure yeah yeah yeah
I don't even know why Elon what did Elon
do what do you mean what did he do I
don't know what he what I don't know
what he did this week you or is that
just end of the year we saying oh well I
mean we've got in of year and elon's on
there he was on the poll I'm sure he
didn't even come close um as you he was
he was the lowest of them all oh man
that sucked yeah and and he [__] up a
lot of [__] this year so he did you know
the one that I didn't get I I was like
oh who should I do is the is the DM no
well here's the thing we're not have a
lot of time so I'm gonna stay focused on
the major [__] do it because I get
you know I got that but I I want to go
back to this primary thing yeah um so
let me let me let me find your ass your
ass sets here real quick assets your ass
your ass s and I just want to say the
reason I was late this morning is I woke
up and feeling like [__] if anyone who's
just G you know I got my I got my mug of
tea you know I'm
is but is the muga tea is it is it uh
infused with bubbles that's what I want
to know do you do you bubble your tea no
that's gross oh okay all right well all
right I'm gonna go back to the the
primary speaking of gross I'm gonna go
back to the primaries here real quick I
want to show people this yeah so the New
Hampshire primary it's got 22 delegates
and you can see that the Iowa caucus has
40 so if Trump wins 40 here Gabe Sanchez
and then he wins 22 he's got 62 at that
point when he's won all of them I don't
know if you know how percentage is but
100% uh it works now what is 100% of
100% it it's 100% so but if Nikki but if
Nikki Haley if Nikki Haley wins at New
Hampshire like some people say uh
delusionally that she's going to win uh
then she'll have 22 oh baby that sounds
like not as many as 40 um and then you
go down to the Nevada Republican caucus
I don't know if anyone knows anything
about a Nevada but all 26 of these are
going to go to Donald Trump which I
don't know if you know percentages even
if Nikki Haley wins 22 here that gives
him
4066 um now the Virgin Islands yeah yeah
yeah but here is the key moment what
it's four delegates what do you want
from I know you're like Yeah The Virgin
Island yeah yeah what whatever whatever
whatever whatever that territory that
territory over there giving four
delegates now here's the key moment for
Nikki Haley and the reason why this is
A's not going to win her home state no
no it is important that she win her home
state for several different reasons one
because she won't be able to continue if
she can't win her home state because it
really looks really bad that you were
the governor of a state and then people
like n we'd rather have someone else you
suck um now the other thing too is it
comes with 50 delegates Gabe Sanchez it
comes with 50 of them wow 5 zero that's
that's a big number to go to not Haley
right really needs that she would really
need this at this point even if she wins
New Hampshire because he be
70 yeah he's going to kill her now the
next big the next big day is March 2nd
okay and the Idaho caucus and if you
know anything about Idaho it's
definitely not going to Nikki Haley
udaho Michigan Michigan is not going to
Nicki Hale there's 39 there so those are
significant numbers that are going to go
to I don't know Donald Trump and then
you get all the way down to the next big
day which is super Tuesday it is the day
after the imaginary trial that everyone
thinks is still going to happen on March
4th um but hey you know as Justin Bieber
says Never Say Never right yeah exactly
all right so if you know anything about
Alabama Arkansas I don't know Colorado
man look at my state over there
California look how many 169 now they
tried to box Trump out of this primary
but they didn't actually they made it
actually more secure for him for the 169
so when Nikki Haley even if
hypothetically she we go with Al
alternative reality and we go with what
[__] boxes on the internet say um
because they don't know what the [__]
they're talking about let's say they she
wins 22 delegates by the time we get the
super Tuesday H she's gonna lose so I
don't I don't know how to make it more
clear I hope that clears it up for
everyone why Nicki Haley won't be the
nominee I hope that clears it up yeah
for folks why see you see Ronda sanz's
recent interview where they were like
would you ever team up with her and he's
like why would I I mean like you know
commendable for Ronda santis to really
dig his heels in but wait wait wait he
might want to because maybe maybe he
might want to but he's now publicly said
on when this question came up they
followed up after this and they said
would you be willing to team up and he
was like why would I do that well he W
here's I'm gonna give you a reason why
yeah know why let's let Nikki Haley
explain why Ronda Sanz might want to
team up with Nikki Haley let's listen
and this of course is referring back to
New hampsh sure you were asked to
explain the cause of the Civil War you
obviously did not mention slavery and
afterward you came up you said that was
a mistake in fact you said it should
thing that you said so you did come out
and say
thaty though came out and said that you
gave that answer not because in his
you're in his words dumb or racist but
because you're quote unwilling to offend
anyone by telling
truth what do you say to that no one's
ever said that I am unwilling to offend
I offend plenty of people because I call
people out when they do something wrong
because I try to take your I will tell
you is Chris Christie is from New Jersey
yeah I should have said slavery right
off the bat you should have y but if you
grow up in South Carolina oh where it's
pretty big in second and third grade you
learn about slavery oh my God you grow
up you hear that they learned about it
in second grade Gabe Sanchez so you
think you think that if you learned
about it that early I don't know where
this whole like well he's from New
Jersey and I'm from South Carolina where
I don't know it was pretty big you know
we also got the 13 colonies we got the
other stuff started like pretty crucial
to the foundation of this country and
you've got her saying well we learned
about in second and third grade so then
what's your excuse for not talking about
it well let me get to the part let me
get to the part where the reason why
Ronda Santa should pair up with Nikki
Haley because there's one there's one
critical reason and it's a oneperson
type reason but but listen and you have
you know I had black friends growing up
oh she had a black she had a black
friend she she listen gab Sanchez Nikki
Haley knows knows a black person this is
the reason why this is the reason why
Ronda santz would want to pair up with
Nikki Haley because then he could be
black friend adjacent you know what I
mean there's no way that Ronda Sanz has
a black friend but you know what I mean
you know what I mean I mean he would
probably say like look I got a black
friend I think the only black friend
that Ronda sandz has is the Florida
Surgeon General do you think that's his
friend or do you think it's like that's
like Donald Trump be like where's my
africanamerican where's my African
American these people she they just
claim people as property which is really
[__] up I can't even I can't even tell
you a question about slavery like Nikki
Haley gets a question about slavery and
I'm sure they were like look do not do
not when someone asks you about a
question about slavery do do not say the
words I have a black friend do not ever
ever ever in the history of ever say
those words when you're talking about
slavery So Not only was she like Civil
War wasn't about slavery [__] slav it
was about rats States rats and then
we're like I messed up it was about
slavery but I got a black friend yeah
but it's okay it's okay quick Mulligan
right because I got a black friend I got
a black any anytime look anytime someone
uh is asked a question about something
that is you know uh bigoted derogatory
uh just insulting any way that's that is
against a marginalized Community your
first response should not be I have a
friend of said group and think that
that's just like washes away the sin
like it's you're being baptized this is
not something that you can just like
clean away and say oh let me restart I
have a black friend so as a result what
I said before or rather what I didn't
say before about slavery and the Civil
War let's forget about that okay I've
got a black friend right I got a black
friend I got a black friend oh boy
speaking of she's a bonehead but
speaking of bone EDS let's go to boned
of the week there we go all right oh so
SM oo o smooth transition I haven't done
this in a while boom it's actually
bonehead of the year is what we're doing
bonee head of the year I I suggested
bone of the year to Gabe Sanchez he
couldn't make it last week uh on Friday
because he was traveling in his at the
time non-car car but would have been his
car car he would had current car but but
when I texted you I was like look man
even in the final hours we've got people
entering the race like Lauren robbert
was one of them right so you made a good
point like hey this could be a thing
where up until the 11th hour we got
people still throwing their name in
being like they're not boneheaded un
boneheaded right well and you know our
bonee heads actually we boneheaded
pretty much all year long yeah so the
the three nominees that we come up with
were pretty much yeah just absolute
[__] Bon heads but that's how it goes
that's how it goes with the bonehead of
the week so let's start Bon head of the
week
2023 year Edition here in 2024 did I get
that right big step in she's always
she's been on I I got 2023 and 24 mixed
up they me keeping me honest they keep
me honest it's easy to mix up you know
keeping me honest well 2024 is if you
thought 2023 was wild boy do I got a
story to tell you 2024 is gonna be crazy
Banger speaking of bangers let's do the
let's do the the noise
yeah
[Applause]
all right let's go through this really
quick because I just want to get to the
winner here is what I want to do Elon
Musk um what are some of the boneheaded
things that Elon Musk did this year
let's just make a list of some of the
bonee headed things and then we'll go to
comr pile over there and
I'll he continued to push uh Twitter
down the [__] uh by mean xchan xchan
xchan by saying hey no no no it's free
speech even the anti-Semitism the racism
and all that stuff which then goes into
the point when he was called up by Media
Matters and they're like hey here are
screenshots of pro- Hitler anti-semitic
posts right under or above sponsored
post that companies are paying sponsored
ads for and then he goes well Media
Matters being really mean I'm going to
have a lawsuit file against them which
is there's no no grounds for that to
stand on because it's literally your
it's it's how your algorithm feeds those
things together and if I'm a you know
it's a free market capitalism I'm a
company doesn't want to be there I pull
out which then goes to Elon Musk at the
uh New York Times uh uh speaker event
and he's like [__] advertisers go [__]
yourself uh am I being clear enough go
[__] yourself which is a great thing to
do when you're in a crowd with the
advertisers who you literally need to
bankr the rest of this before you have
to start putting even more money into
the company which then goes into the
Cyber truck launch which was a [__]
flop and uh what else was there anything
else I mean there's a lot of Elon stuff
there was the I mean there was the you
went to the border with the cowboy hat
backwards there was so much stuff but at
the end of the year I want to say at the
end of the year we had Grimes who came
in at the
end because her affiliation with
obviously Elon is that they're still
kind of so so uh hooking up uh or
whatever hooking up hooking up they're
like hooking up is that is that what the
sound it
makes no actually it wouldn't be that
loud it' be like is he is he buying her
hores is that is that what he might be I
mean look lot of a lot of hores there's
exchanges going on theast two kids
together I think the other thing that I
just thought of uh another one is the r
STIs launch on on on on Twitter that was
a great boneheaded moment in that was
great when it was like a bunch of Echo
and Reverb and it was this is terrible
so at the end of the year uh Grimes goes
basically was like yeah white white
power uh or white she basically was like
she basically said like uh yeah I'm
proud to be
white wow yeah because there was a whole
conversation of Nazis and and uh White
Nation wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait okay the words I'm proud
to be white uhuh are words that you
should be careful using in any context
but in the context of of Nazis and
nationalism white power is a thing that
you probably should be very careful look
this is the headline Grime says she's
proud of white culture that's what it
was proud of white culture after being
labeled
a Nazi the singer was called a white
supremacist amid backlash online and her
response was here's the Tweet I'm called
a Nazi because I here I'll I'll send you
the Tweet really quick so that people
can see we're not making this up this is
what she said I don't make [__] up I
mean sometimes all right I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna lie when we're joking
around we making fun and we're doing
stuff I I I tend to make jokes and make
make this is it this is the tweet so
basically she was called
a na here it is here's the Tweet oh [__]
I got the wrong there there we are
that's I'm call Nazi because I happily
am proud of white cult what wh what yeah
I mean I mean that maybe the reason why
people are calling you a Nazi is because
of your your proud your white pride um
White Power white pride I mean that
might be that I mean that could be it if
you're like you're like white power
white power then yeah people are
probably going to call you [__] Nazi
and also if you're like you know you're
uh co-parenting or hooking up with
another guy Elon Musk who is a Nazi and
has a platform that supports and
promotes white supremacy and
anti-Semitism on the platform as well as
other I mean like even the clip that you
sent me last night holy [__] wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait she did a Nikki
Haley I'm just reading it she said but
every day I think finally of the brown
King Cyrus the Great who invented the
first ever Empire and the Japanese icon
I'm not sure how you say wrote the first
novel ever she's like I don't have a
black friend but I know of people in
history that aren't white yeah like this
is it's it's it reminds me of el she was
like history teach us all that we've all
been and always will be great okay
that's like Elon must being like I love
all humans I love them all right she
what if humans all loved each other well
that's great and all and I would love to
live in a Utopia like that but here's
the thing we don't in the internet is
kerosene when it's allowed that these
people these white supremacist bigoted
racist anti-semitic people who go online
and are able to freely safely securely
say those things on this platform oh
like they did last night that video holy
[__] whoa that was a wild one Speaking
of anti-semites
oh well I'm not going to get to him yet
hang on hang on to it we're going to go
to this this has to do with Donald Trump
but the reason why James comr pile is on
the list is really only one reason is
because he boneheaded got presidents
confused did you hear this news he got
he got confused he thought he thought
the evidence showed that that Hunter
Biden the son of a president was taking
Chinese bribes and giving it to Joe
Biden his dad he got it all wrong he
confused the president's it was actually
the other guy that did it let's watch
the Biden family and they're making
millions from now think of this from
China too could you imagine me doing
that or my son's doing that
no doing that a years long investigation
by democrats on the house oversight
committee claims former president
Trump's businesses received at least
$7.8 million from foreign governments
during his time in office according to
the report a bulk of of those payments
came from the Chinese government and
state-owned business the family uh oh
now I this is all about Trump because
they're trying comr pile the other the
other nominee for bone end of the week
has been trying his damnest all year
wrong along with his um his friend his
friend and cohort Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan but James comr really is
the dumbest of the dumb if you got a
really dumb clip you want me to play of
him that would be great if you send it
um actually I don't need to play a dumb
clip of him the only clip I really need
to play play is of Ducey oh really oh
yeah yeah that would be great um but the
long and the short of it is is he's been
investigating the wrong president
apparently and comr pile is such a
bonehead he didn't even realize that
that he was investigating the wrong
president and the wrong president's son
uh
[Music]
apparently
LC
James qan on comr LLC I bet that's I bet
that's the name of the LLC I bet that's
I bet that's the name of it uh no doubt
that's the name of the LLC but comr pile
made the um made the list this year as
bonehead so we got Elon we got comr pile
and if you got that clip just throw it
there and I got that clip I got that
clip dog um which which Dey is it which
Dey is it Steve oh this is this is this
is Steve duy oh yeah okay all right I I
I I recognize this yeah this clip I
smell what I smell what you're stepping
in here oh yeah you're picking up what
I'm putting down here here is Steve
Ducey H douchy I think we're saying it
wrong it's douch right duch duch okay
duch is it is that French du du yeah
it's it's French we say it's French okay
all right all right here we go let's L
let's listen to Frenchie um talk about
comr here house oversight committee has
been at this for years and they have so
far not been able to provide any
concrete evidence that Joe Biden
personally profited from his son
Hunter's overseas business but they are
going to try again with this impeachment
inquiry that's set to start next week
still Peter thanks very much indeed see
you again
soon cut cut cut cut cut so that that is
the story uh in a in in a nutshell yeah
um which which is douchi duch's brain
pile but then also comr getting exposed
for doing the same exact thing that he
went after Joe Biden for which is the
$200,000 loan for his brother because
remember they were like it's five it's
10 it's 25 it's $100 million and also
there's a $200,000 loan there's only two
checks that we can show one was for a
car payment for his son and the other
was between his brother and Joe Biden
and then you're like okay well what's
going on and like well this clearly
shows that they're criminals and it's
like does it really or does it just show
it's a personal loan that was paid back
and then you find out that James comr
used the shell Co Corp or shell company
did land swaps with his brother and one
of the values of the checks was paid out
to $200,000 and now people are going to
James Comer's Hometown and they're now
looking into his business dealing so you
know what well deserved you [__] went
knocking and somebody opened the door
and didn't like you at the front door
right you opened Pandora or's box and
now you've got a can of whoop ass coming
out on you man whoop ass whoop ass
speaking of whoop ass and Pandora's Box
it brings us to the winner of bonad
bonehead of the year for 2023 geez what
a year this guy had huh Donald Jessica
Trump oh my God now okay so let let's
play a game here because we could play
so many clips of him being a bon head
yeah like it's just I mean we wouldn't
we we could play so many Clips we could
do six 2our shows with just clips of him
being a bon so I want you to tell me
what is your most favorite boneheaded
Donald Trump moment of 2023 what is what
would be the thing would be the cherry
on I mean the top the top one I've got a
couple but the top one that I would say
is when he's like I'd only be a bon
[Laughter]
head I'd don't I'd only be a bonee head
for a just day one only on day one I'd
be a bon head excuse me excuse me very
rude okay let me be a bonehead okay
don't stop me now uh no the one clip
that I would say is when he basically
was like yeah I'll only be a dictator
for a day just just on day one just one
day let me be a dictator and you're like
dictators are not they no dictator walks
in and goes yeah I only want it for 24
hours now we'll go back to the
democratic system as it was before we
you know we'll go we'll go back to an
equal justice process everyone has the
their equal voice and N you know what
actually no no dictator has ever walked
in and say ah you know what 20 24 hours
is enough I just want a day want a day
one I look I I don't want to indulge
just want to try it out right right well
here here is a here's a glimpse into the
picture of Donald Trump being bonehead
uh for a day oh excuse me dick taster of
a day here here's oh yes right
only only excuse me excuse okay excuse
me very rude let me be a dict taster
okay love I'm many people are saying I'm
the best
dictator many people are saying that now
I'm gonna I'm gonna build on your moment
okay that you picked out I'm gonna build
on your moment you picked out because I
think now that I'm looking at this image
here um when I think of boneheaded
moments in 2023 cuz the dictator for one
day like he's been indicted he's been
saying that Maraga is worth1 and a half
billion dollars I mean money okay so
many boned things Tony I just want to
say dict tasers don't become
billionaires overnight okay a lot of
dicks got a taste gotta make
money that is a lot of dicks to taste
for a billion and a half dollars but the
moment that I think really sealed the
deal for me like this dictator thing is
going to [__] bury him and we can use
this and it's going to be every issue
with this guy is when he got on stage
like you would think he'd come away from
that moment that you just described and
be like I should probably never say that
again like Aaron Rogers should never
mention Jimmy Kimmel's name again yeah
unless he wants to be broke I mean I
feel like this is where Will Smith comes
in he's like keep my name or keep my
wife's name out your [__] mouth
M keep dictator out your [__]
mouth keep dictator out your
[__] mouth oh oh you said
dictater yeah that's fine you could yeah
yeah yeah you could say dictater just
not dictator yeah but here's the thing
the moment where he got on stage and he
was like look I know it sounds like I'm
saying what Hitler's saying out of minec
I've never read minec and by the way
Hitler said it different he said it in
German what the [__] are you doing man
keep going don't understand okay okay
it's very simple he said mine C and I
said mine comp okay mine
comp literally the guy the guy gets on
stage what what do you
got I'm sitting through an earthquake
right now are you serious yeah is it is
it
going earthquake live on Air camera
Shake sh was like what the [__] this is
the Deep State this is the Deep State
there's like a little bit Aftershock
okay okay anyone in La okay here we go
anyone in La feel that right now
did you did you feel the dick taster
give we got people boom we say yes we
got people who are feeling it oh man
people said yeah caretaker caretaker
said uh they oh sorry sorry I'm I'm SC
Perry said he
farted Perry said he farted wild I don't
know that was like an Aftershock but I
felt something there too anyway that was
wild I was like oh why is my camera
shaking and I was like oh
[__] full on full on deep AK earthquake
this is and there was an earthquake a
couple days ago too there was one on uh
New Year's Day I it was like 9 9 in the
morning maybe 10 in the morning eight
something like that or ear not too late
but 8 N1 in the morning out here there
was another earthquake that happened uh
start the year baby that was wild wo it
didn't it didn't show much on the T on
the screen yeah I think it's you should
like grabbed your camera and really gave
it the good earthquake effect yeah like
if I we would believe you that way we
would believe you I mean some people
verified it in the
chat four
4.6 uh BW Rock Says 4.6 east of LA just
happened that's
4.6 uh I'll give it a
4.6 um right now but here's the thing
here's the thing your camera uh action
was like a 1.2 it was not a 4.6 I'm just
yeah I'm just I'm looking up on the
earthquake website right now it
says where was this earthquake news live
on the Tony Michaels podcast I mean you
don't get it anywhere else I'll tell you
that much you don't get the [__] live
dog s Gabriel mountains is where it was
up in so North just north of Rancho
Cucamonga dude um yeah east of east of
where I live but uh that was wild crazy
it it sounds like it was a trump
girthquake
um oh my God all right well that's the
Bonet of the year and of course you know
who won it was very easy it was an easy
competition he won without any
competition oh he's going to come that's
maybe what it was that may what it was
that's what it was excuse me excuse me
gotta let the dict taster come okay
gotta let him come I'm gonna come I'm
gonna come I you know what's funny about
that is because I was trying to figure
out the order that I was going to put
him in I sent them to you in a different
order and I knew this would happen so uh
here is your phallic horse race for Bon
head of the Year 2023 Grant Paul
Hitler gab Sanchez let's give him his
[Music]
[Applause]
due
[Music]
oh leave it up to me to put Grandpa
Hitler in the middle so that it looks
excuse me did you see did you see how
big that dick was okay it's going to
taste even better so huge I'm tiny BGE
big dick huge in the mouth for the
tasting okay love dick taste just dick
taste for a day guys just dick taster
for a day no big deal no big deal okay
many people are saying many people
excuse me excuse me many people are
saying that I'd be the best dick taster
okay many people many people hey there's
my dick taster okay you
know game Sanchez bonee head of the week
of the year 2023 stick around stick
around don't go anywhere with this
earthquake of news because we got some
we got some announcements right after
the music Gabe Sanchez is gonna talk
about what was that
[Music]
[Applause]
live
Gabe Sanchez Bonet of the week yeah I'm
so glad to have you back on me tonny
Michaels podcast the audience loves
having you here they love watching your
show what was that live over the
holidays over the holidays uh your
schedule changed a bit and it's going to
be changing this year this year is going
to bring in a new year and a new
schedule for what was that live and I
wanted you to take a moment to tell the
audience what that schedule is possibly
going to look like for 2024 yeah so
we're still going to work on the Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday schedule o but I have
to uh move it from the mornings to the
evening oh so in the evening I'm
thinking right now it'll possibly be
five o'clock uh is your time is that
your time that's my time so Pacific so
five o'clock Pacific or 5:30 Pacific I'm
starting to nail on which one will be
best but it'll be in the evening at that
time Tuesday Wednesday Thursday so same
as it was before just we're gonna push
it a few hours later evening prime time
oh yeah what was that with Gabe Sanchez
so here's the thing um if everyone's
listening and we're GNA try to work this
out where um because it used to be it
used to could and it used to be where
when my show ended it would go to Gabe
Sanchez's show but I think we can still
make it go to that link so what you'll
do on Tuesday Wednesday Thursday is
you'll be watching the Tony Michaels
podcast it'll end and then you'll go to
the waiting room for Gabe Sanchez is
what was that live and you can save it
you can make it to where you can push
the notification so to let you know when
he goes live later that evening um so
we'll be doing that for a while and make
sure do not forget to do this because
you're you're not going to want to miss
those evening shows go over to
youtube.com/ gab Sanchez or go to I am
gab sanchez. comom click the YouTube
channel or you can go to the Tony
michaels.com gab Sanchez's YouTube
channel is down there go subscribe to
his YouTube channel that's where you'll
find what was that live now if you're on
Twitch you can also subscribe to his
twitch Channel you can find it at I amav
sanchez. and if you're on the books of
face well you're [__] you're just
[__] you do that you didn't do that
you didn't do the faceb sorry I just
don't do I don't are you doing Instagram
though are you doing Instagram I might I
gotta play with it I just saw I just saw
a notification today that play with what
Instagram or yourself my both oh okay at
the same you know whatever hey why not
both right on play with myself on
Instagram friend okay why not myself
on that might you know what I actually
now that I'm thinking about that might
really increase your Following over on
Instagram if you play with yourself on
Instagram I just don't know how that'll
work with Community violations yeah you
might have to do that on PornHub or feat
finder or like only fans or something
yeah um
the look man if I can make
money this why you got kicked off
Facebook and you can't go over there is
because you that's why Zu was like
nobody can do what yeah Sanchez can't be
doing dirty Sanchez's on the books of
face it's not okay my friend um but what
I will say yeah is uh I came I signed in
today and I saw that you can now it you
can see the comments from Twitter yes
you can so I considered broadcasting to
Twitter again because of that yeah
because before you couldn't see the
comments so it's like you were just
[__] something out in the universe
it's the same thing with Instagram
though you don't get to see the comments
so like and and you don't even get to
see the broadcast when you broadcast on
Instagram once it's done it's like it's
gone it's poop yeah it's like it just wh
it doesn't even exist anymore she lter
right it just shits the bed as soon as
you exit off so so the news the story is
that make sure to go follow Gabe Sanchez
YouTube channel and his twitch Channel
if you're trying to find him on Facebook
you're looking in the wrong spot because
he's not on Facebook but go follow go
follow them on on all the social medias
Twitter xchan Instagram Ticky talk all
the all the all the things yeah yeah
yeah I am ganz.com but don't forget that
here on the Tony Michaels podcast we
will not be shooting directly to him on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday it'll be the
evening time it is what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez in prime time
make sure you're subscribed in my [__]
too I mean why ask here if you're not
subscri course of course I don't want to
promote you too much you know what I
mean can't do that can't do that passed
the 20K Mark did you really yeah I
passed congratulations me us too but I
think I passed it uh like a few days
before the the New Year okay yeah well
well Merry Christmas uh to you then you
dirty animal and no filthy Jesus Christ
well look I'm a dirty sanchez this say
you
know guy with the last name Sanchez I'm
so glad you're back on the show the
audience is Glen you're back here don't
forget again I am gab sanchez. go follow
his YouTube channel that what was that
live with the guy with the last name
sanchz will be moving to the evening
time on Tuesday Wednesday Thursday it'll
let you know that's why you need to
follow that's why you need to subscribe
that's why you need to do all that stuff
go to I am gab sanchez. you'll find it
or you can go to Theon michaels.com
while you're at Theon michaels.com click
on all those [__] buttons too click
on the buttons over there on those Gabe
Sanchez have a great weekend audience to
have a great weekend don't do anything I
wouldn't do or just do all the [__] I
would do and get in all kinds of trouble
until Monday same time same place surf
sub [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear
here we hope you enjoyed the show and
we'll be back soon in the meantime
follow Tony on social media at@ the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
as soon as we arrived it was shut down
to less than 50 that's because the drug
cartels control the action and the
activity the flow of migrants in and out
and they control the action so they did
not want that as part of the pictures
that we saw nor that the national media
saw so what you were looking at is where
we were at Eagle Pass Texas there is the
famous bridge right there that also
includes a train trestle and car traffic
virtually empty yesterday because the
cartels know that they're under
increased scrutiny by the American
people but when we showed up shut it to
nothing yeah as soon
as